قال زعيم المعارضه الاسرائيليه يائير
لابيد ان التسريبات بخصوص ما شهده المجلس
الوزاري المصغر للشؤون السياسيه والامنيه
في اسرائيل من توتر وصراخ بين المجتمعين
الليله الماضيه وصمه عار ودليل اخر على
خطوره هذه الحكومه واضاف لابيد في منشور
على منصه اكس انه يجب على اسرائيل تبديل
الحكومه ورئيسها لانها غير قادره على
تحقيق قرار استراتيجي وفق تعبيره
معها من رام الله وليد العمري مدير مكتب
الجزيره وليد المزيد حول هذه الخلافات
التي شهدها هذا
الاجتماع هذا الاجتماع الذي استمر نحو
ثلاث ساعات ونصف الساعه عمليا انهار مما
اضطر نتنياهو الى فضه وذلك بعد ان كانت
مجموعه من وزراء اليمين المتطرف تحديد
الصهيونيه الدينيه سموتريش وبن كفير وكذلك
وزيران مقربان من نتنياهو من الليكود هم
ريجف وايضا ام سالم قد شنوا هجوما شرسا و
بالالفاظ سيئه حسب وصف احد الوزراء على
رئيس هيئه الاركان العسكريه هيرتس هاليفي
وان الاصوات والصراخ قد تعالى بشكل منفر
كما قال احدهم ونقلت الاذاعه الاسرائيليه
قبل قليل عن احد الوزراء قوله الذي حضر
الاج مع قوله لمراسلها بان ما جرى كان
بمثابه مذبحه لرئيس هيئه الاركان وقد
انبرى الوزراء من حزب المعسكر الرسمي بيني
جانس وزملائه وكذلك وزير الدفاع يواف
جالنت للدفاع عن رئيس هيئه الاركان بينما
وصف وزير اخر بان نتنياهو ربما كان
مستمتعا بهذا الصراخ والخلاف او كما وصفها
هذه المعركه في داخل الطاقم الوزاري
الامني السياسي المصغر المعروف بالكابينه
والذي من المفترض انه هو من يصنع القرارات
التي تصله بعدها التوصيات من هيئات مختلفه
لكن واضح ان هذا الاجتماع الذي كان مخصصا
لبحث مساله هامه وهي مساله اليوم التالي
للحرب في حال انتهت هذه الحرب كما تشتهي
اسرائيل بالطبع الا انه تم تاجيلها مره
اخرى وهي المره الثالثه التي يذهب نتنياهو
لتاجيل هذا الموضوع خلال هذا الاسبوع
والمطلوب منه ان يتخذ قرارا ايضا لعرضه
على وزير الخارجيه الامريكيه الذي سيصل
اسرائيل الاسبوع المقبل في اطار جوله شرق
اوسطيه هامه وستكون تلك زيارته الخامسه
الاجتماع كما قلت انها اضطر نتنياهو الى
فضه بعد كل الصراخ الذي تعالى هؤلاء
الوزراء الاربعه هاجموا ايه ورئيس هيئه
الاركان العسكريه لتعيينه لجنه داخليه
لهيئه رئاسه الاركان والجيش للتحقيق في
امرين هما الاخفاق او الفشل الذريع الامني
الاستخباراتي والعسكري في مواجهه عمليه
طوفان الاقصى التي نفذتها كتائب القسام في
السابع من شهر اكتوبر الماضي وكذلك مسار
الحرب على غزه المتواصله منذ 91 ودخلت
اليوم يومها الدي اي بدايه شهرها الرابع
لكن هؤلاء هاجموه لانه اختار شاؤول موفاز
وزير الدفاع الاسبق في عهد حكومه ارييل
شارون اختاره رئيسا لهذه اللجنه وكان
موفاز هو وزير الدفاع الذي قاد عمليه
الانسحاب والانفصال عن غزه في تموز عام
2005 واعتبروه ذلك بانه جزء من التامر من
جانب هيرتس هاليفي ل لان شاؤول مفاز كما
قالوا له كان جزءا من هذه ال النظريه
القائمه على الانسحاب من غزه سياتي
بالهدوء وانهم يرفضون ذلك وتعالى الصراخ
في داخل هذه الجلسه نتنياهو من ناحيته ذهب
هو الاخر للتدخل وقال لهرتز هاليفي ان
عليك ان تستمع لانتقادات الوزراء وهذا زاد
من حده التوتر خاصه وان العلاقات اصلا بين
نتنياهو وبين وزير دفاعه يف جلنت وكذلك
الوزير في مجلس الحرب بيني جانس هي متوتره
في الاساس العالمون ببواطن الامور قالوا
بان ما جرى يعكس تعمق ازمه الثقه داخل
دائره صنع القرار في اسرائيل علما ان هناك
ازمه ثقه متفاقم ايضا بين الشارع
الاسرائيلي وقيادته السياسيه لكنها شهدت
ترميمات العسكريه و وجاء ذلك في وقت ايضا
كان فيه ذو الاسرائيليين الاسرى
والمحتجزين في قطاع غزه يتظاهرون على
مقربه من المكان في مجمع قياده الاجهزه
الامنيه والجيش ووزاره الدفاع ورئاسه
الاركان في تل ابيب والمعروفه بالكر وهي
الموقع الاهم والاكثر حساسيه الذي منه
تصنع القرارات ايضا وتدار هذه الحرب وما
سبقها من حروب ايضا وامور امنيه كثيره
لذلك ما جرى يوصف بانه يؤشر على ان
الحكومه وكما قال زعيم المعارضه يائير
لبيد قبل قليل في تغريده قال بانه يعكس
بان هذه الحكومه ورئيسها يجب استبدالهم
بسرعه لانهم ليسوا اهلا اصلا لقياده
اسرائيل ولا لقياده الحرب الدائره حاليا
هذه تعكس حاله من التوتر داخل دائره صنع
القرار وتعكس حاله من ازمه الثقه بين
الوزراء انفسهم وبينهم وبين رئيسهم ايضا
وتعكس الصراع القائم داخل هذه المجالس حول
القضايا المصيريه سواء ما يتعلق منها
بمسار الحرب او المخططات التي يعتقد البعض
بانه سيكون قادر على تنفيذها وتحديدا من
اليمين المتطرف ممثل بالصهيونيه الدينيه
وكذلك بعض اطراف اللكود الحاكم مثل مخططات
لتهجير قصري لسكان قطاع غزه الفلسطينيين
وكذلك لاعاده بناء استيطان فيها وما شابه
والتي تعالت حولها الكثير من التقولات
والتصريحات في الفتره الاخيره واحدى اهداف
زياره وزير الخارجيه الامريكيه بلينكن هو
وضع حد نهائي لمثل هذه التصريحات ومنع اي
تهجير قصري للمواطنين الفلسطينيين من قطاع
غزه وهو ما سيبحث مع قاده المنطقه وكذلك
مع المسؤولين سواء في اسرائيل او مع
السلطه الفلسطينيه في رام الله وسيعمل
ايضا على محاوله تحرير الاموال التي
تحتجزها الحكومه الاسرائيليه والمستحقه
عليها للجانب الفلسطيني بالاضافه بطبيعه
الحال محاوله تهدئه ما توصف بالتصريحات
الناريه التي تؤجج المواقف ومحاوله تبديد
التوتر ومنع انفجار الموقف على الجبهه مع
لبنان ومحاوله مضاعفه ادخال المساعدات
التي توصف الانسانيه ضروريه للحياه حسب
تعبير البيان الامريكي التي سيتم ادخالها
على قطاع غزه واسرائيل لديها مخططات بخصوص
قطاع غزه وان تبقيه تحت سيطرتها الامنيه
مثلما اعلن رئيس حكومتها مرارا ولكن ان
تناط اداره الشؤون المدنيه فيها لجهات لا
تمت للسط السلطه الفلسطينيه او لحماس او
لفتح او لاي فصيل فلسطيني بصله وهذا هو
محور خلاف داخلي في اسرائيل يزداد يوما
تلو الاخر وواضح انه عندما تضع هذه الحرب
او زارها ستنهار هذه الحكومه التي تعرف
بحكومه الطوارئ التي انضم اليها جانس
وحزبه فقط من اجل اداره الحرب وربما تذهب
اسرائيل مباشره اما الى انتخابات ولكن
بالتاكيد ستتجه الى لجنه تحقيق رسميه قد
تطيح برؤوس كبيره ومن بينها نتنياهو
المتهم من قبل كثيرين بانه يحاول دحرجه
المسؤوليه عن هذه الحرب وعن الفشل الذريع
في السابع من اكتوبر على القياده العسكريه
والامنيه وتحديدا على رئيس هيئه الاركان
هرتس هاليفي وهذا ايضا من اسباب التوتر
والانفجار الاجتماع للطاقم الوزاري الامني
المصغر الليله الماضيه وانهياره واضطرار
نتنياهو الى فضه والان بعد ان انهار هذا
الاجتماع وليد ماذا بعد هل هناك جلسه
مقرره لمناقشه هذه الامور ام
ماذا هذا الاجتماع جاء بعد اجتماع لمجلس
الحرب الذي يضم نتنياهو ووزير الدفاع جلنت
ووزير والوزير في مجلس الحرب جانس وكذلك
ايزن كوت ووزير الشؤون
الاستراتيجيه الموالي لنتنياهو
وواضح بانه لا يمكن للامور ان تتوقف
وسيتواصل لكن لا يبدو ان اجتماعا جديدا
سيكون قريبا من اجل البت في هذا الامور
ونتنياهو يبدو انه يحاول التهرب من خلال
ذلك لكي لا يضطر الى بحث الموضوع مع وزير
الخارجيه بلينكن لانه يدرك جيدا بانه يبدو
ليس هناك وفاق على وجهات النظر او على
رؤيه محدده اسرائيليه بخصوص اليوم التالي
للحرب كي يطرحها على الوزير الامريكي وانه
في حال ايه وفي حال تم بحث الموضوع
ومحاوله حسمه سيصطدم اما بوزراء الصهيونيه
الدينيه الرافضين تماما ويريدون ابقاء
قطاع غزه محتلا تحت السيطره الاسرائيليه
لاطول مده ممكنه واعاده الاستيطان فيه
وتهجير سكانه ايه او انه سيصطدم بوزير
دفاعه والقياده العسكريه وكذلك حزب
المعسكر الرسمي بقياده جانس الذي يضغط
عليه من اجل اتخاذ قرار بهذا الشان لذلك
هو عمليا في ورطه ف لذلك يلعب ويناور بين
الجانبين كي لا يحسم الموضوع وكي لا يضطره
بالتالي الى الصدام او دخول في صدام مع
احد الطرفين نتنياهو يدرك جيدا بانه يرضخ
لمطالب وشروط الصهيونيه الدينيه خاصه
سموتريتش وبن كفير وبعض وزراء حزبه وانه
اذا لم يملي ما يريدون او على الاقل يتهرب
ولا يحسم الامر فانهم يهددون بالانسحاب من
الحكومه انسحابهم من الحكومه معنى ذلك
انهيار توليفته اليمينيه المتطرفه وفي
نهايه المطاف انهيار حكومته وتوليف واذا
انهارت هذه التوليفه نتنياهو يواجه ثلاث
ملفات فساد يحاكم عليها في المحكمه كذلك
ان لجنه التحقيق سيكون ضعيفا في مواجهتها
ان لم يكن على راس الحكومه الاسرائيليه
هذه الامور مجتمعه تجعله يحاول ان يناور
ويحاول ان يماطل في حس اسم هذا الامر
المطالب به من الولايات المتحده
وكذلك من القيادات العسكريه والامنيه
الاسرائيليه التي منذ اكثر من ثلاثه
اسابيع وهي تضغط من اجل ان يتم حسمه لان
ليس هناك رؤيه ولا محتوى سياسي اسرائيلي
لهذه الحرب الضروس الداميه التي حتى الان
كل ما انجزته فيها اسرائيل هو المزيد من
الدمار والقتل في قطاع غزه وعلى نطاق واسع
والمعارك يشهد ب بها الجيش الاسرائيلي
بانه يخوض معارك ضاريه وان كان يحقق تقدما
كما قال وانها معارك فوق الارض وتحت الارض
وقد دفع بسبعه الويه لخان يونس بمفردها من
اجل مواجهه قوات القسام هناك نحن لا نتحدث
عن جيشين نتحدث عن جيش اسرائيلي عرمرم
ونتحدث عن مقاومين فلسطينيين مؤطرين في
كتائبه وقوى منظمه مثل كتائب القسام
والمعارك متواصله ويبدو انه انها ستطول
والاسرائيليون انفسهم وعلى لسان قادتهم
سواء كانوا عسكريين ام سياسيين يؤكدون بان
الحرب ستستغرق فتره طويله بداوا يتحدثون
منذ نحو اسبوعين عن انها قد تستغرق عاما
كاملا وانه ستكون لها اثمان باهظه شكرا لك
وليد العمري مدير مكتب الجزيره كنت معنا
من رام الله و